cent vingt mille mètres carrés soit
l'équivalent de 18 terrains de football
à peu près le tout dans un seul bâtiment
sochaux 2022 c'est d'abord ça un lieu
unique pour fabriquer des voitures
aujourd'hui une pièce rentrer sort du
camion sur la partie du bâtiment que
logistique et elle est en libre et aux
process 300 mètres après et toutes les
étapes de préparation de ces camps de
sinistrés font dans ce dans cette
distance 1 200 millions d'euros investis
avec un calcul au plus juste pour éviter
une répercussion sur le coût des
voitures fabriquées à sochaux tout est
optimisé avec l'objectif de conserver
une production de 60 véhicules par heure
le tout en accompagnant les opérateurs
dans un confort de travail plus adéquate
les postes de travail vont être beaucoup
plus ergonomique pour l'opérateur est
l'une des auteures de variables de
travail que ce soit avec des balancelles
avec les squelettes qui nous permettront
d'ajuster au mieux et d'être dans les
meilleures conditions
le sol a également la mentionner qui
sera peint donc l'atmosphère lumineux
beaucoup plus agréable et évidemment on
va aussi beaucoup investir sur la
formation pour les opérateurs avaient
dispensé plus de 750 mille heures de
formation en tout dans cet immense
bâtiment la logistique aura une place
centrale
tout sera automatisé dans l'espace dédié
une première en europe grâce à 120 robot
intelligent ça ne nécessite d'emmener
une palette toutes les 10 secondes en
ligne de production et cette technologie
là
et la seule aujourd'hui qu'on a
identifié capable de répondre à ce
cahier des charges premier test grandeur
nature et première voiture le 13
décembre avec un objectif pour sochaux
devenir le site le plus performant pour
la fabrication des suv en europe